[Musique]
c'est une expo est un podcast et on va
contracter c'est un ex podcasts et donc
c'est une expo qui est une expo
numérique évidemment puisque on est dans
un univers entièrement numérique entre
l'expo et le podcast
[Musique]
molière et la musique sont intimement
liés et que penser jean baptiste
poquelin pensée molière aujourd'hui sans
le relier à la musique et à l'art de
spectacles de son temps c'est perdre une
grande partie de leur vie
[Musique]
il ya deux podcasts différentes pour
être précis il ya un peu de castes en
six épisodes qui est vraiment un podcast
qui nous guide dans les musiques de
molière delà de la jeunesse de molière
le rapport de molière avec la musique et
on va le conduire quasiment jusqu'au
malade imaginaire justement jusqu'à sa
dernière pièce est entre-temps on va
balayer dans cette vie de molière tout
ce que molière va avoir comme lien avec
la musique et on va y trouver aussi un
podcast qu'on a appelée junior mais qui
est vraiment tout public en fait qu'il
s'adresse des les étés le collège et où
on va avoir cinq personnages qui vont
nous présenter leur le rapport à molière
[Musique]